seen a little bit of a warm-up here in
southern Nevada right now about 68
degrees Southern California though is
getting battered with more rain so as if
that wasn't enough the snow melt could
cause new flooding problems as well Ryan
Matthew paid a visit to see just where
it all goes
the San Bernardino Mountains covered in
unprecedented amounts of snow
some areas seen over 12 feet due to
back-to-back storms since February for
weeks this has been a common sight walls
of snow piled high preventing at one
point anybody from coming in or getting
out they haven't seen a storm like this
in over 40 years in Crestline nearly 800
firefighters police and equipment
operators are helping to get them out we
just got to a home today where these
people were dug out after 18 days the
collecting Snow's weight crushing the
roof of this town's primary grocery
store it it I don't even have Awards to
describe and the roofs of those who live
here this is ginger Abad and Rick
goodrich's collapsed patio roof it's
going to be a while till we can get it
fixed because you know even if we get
straight enough with insurance you can't
there's no way to get a contractor now
they joined hundreds who have been stuck
up here for days and are now seeing some
relief as the snow begins to melt but
all that water has to go somewhere and
the question is where it'll run along
the west side of that Jonathan Newby is
a field office chief for the United
States Geological Survey warm weather
would melt it right and and warm rain
would melt it too warm rain would just
melt it a lot faster he's referring to
this past weekend's warm rain event and
more anticipated Tuesday without it he
says a complete melt could take up to a
month slowly draining through a system
of natural courses above and below the
ground on the North Slopes it goes into
the Mojave River but the vast amounts of
snow leaves the possibility of it
reaching Barstow if intense enough it
could go even farther to the dry soda
Lake by Baker he says that's possible
due to drought-stricken California land
we are 70 miles outside of Crestline
here in Barstow in the Mojave River here
drives a bone leaving flooding concerns
for San Bernardino County Public Works
director Brendan Riggs snow absorbs the
rain it can become heavy and take debris
down with it too so that can involve us
cleaning up rocks and debris in addition
to the snow
so as you just heard there that
potential flooding could spill over our
roadways like right on the 15 between
here and Southern California Public
Works says if that happens they do plan
to close impacted roads until they're
cleared now another note here Las Vegas
will not see any of that water as we're
in a higher elevation of course you can
find all that information as well as
breaking news push alerts inside of our
8 News Now app it's available for
download on both Google Play and the App
Store